Eh
tre It's not included
Red seems
voodoo
No, Zack
Big [ __ ] kid game I went to
great lengths to prepare your grave,
but I'm crazy about destroying
it And it seems like I have quite a lot of red
But Zack's tombstone is fine as it is, isn't it? It's perfect for you.
Hmm
I'm
love at first sight I've
always been making brainwaves of corpses killed by other people, so it was a little
boring I like making graves, but I don't like the people I put inside
them 6 That's
not beautiful
Rachel  I want to make her an ideal grave She's
close to my age
Above all, I can understand her feelings I have a lot of feelings for her My
hair is much more beautiful than I want to be one-sided and messy Oh
, even messy if she wants  It's fine, but don't say that you have
bad eyesight My aesthetic and her are a perfect match
That
's why I'm the heart